Jetzt lege ich eine zweite Ebene an,
die erscheint jetzt rot.
Und in meiner zweiten Ebene möchte ich jetzt eine Vorlage
hochladen, um diese zu nutzen,
um dann meine technische Modezeichnung anzufertigen.
Also nenne ich meine zweite Ebene schon einmal Vorlage.
Ihr findet mehrere Vorlagen in eurem Kursbereich unter
PDF-Dateien.
Ladet euch also jetzt die Vorlage runter,
die ihr benutzen wollt, direkt auf euren
Schreibtisch.
Von eurem Schreibtisch aus klickt ihr da drauf und zieht
sie dann auch direkt in den Illustrator rein.
Hier merkt ihr,
dass sie vielleicht von der Größe nicht ganz passt und ihr
sie noch mal transformieren wollt.
Also vielleicht könnt ihr euch erinnern,
ihr geht auf den schwarzen Pfeil,
das Auswahlwerkzeug und könnt jetzt hier die Größe
verändern.
Vorsicht, um sie proportional zu verändern,
haltet ihr gleichzeitig die Shift-Taste gedrückt.
So steht ihr sicher, dass eure Schablone proportional gleich
bleibt und sich nicht deformiert.
Am Anfang kann es immer mal passieren,
dass man in irgendeine komische Funktion reingerät in Adobe
Illustrator und sich plötzlich nicht mehr zurechtfindet.
Falls das mal der ist, keine Panik,
geht einfach mit Cmd oder Ctrl Z ein paar Schritte zurück,
bis ihr wieder in einer normalen Funktion seid oder ihr
macht die Datei zu und öffnet sie wieder und sie wird dann
da geöffnet, wo ihr sie zum letzten Mal
zwischengespeichert habt.
Falls ihr jetzt auch lange nicht mehr zwischengespeichert
habt, dann tut das jetzt.
Wir haben also jetzt unsere Schablone hochgeladen und
platziert an der richtigen Stelle und die Größe angepasst
und jetzt wollen wir noch die Deckkraft von dieser Schablone
verändern, denn das ist ja schließlich nur eine Vorlage und
sie soll ein bisschen im Hintergrund sein, aber jetzt nicht
so prägnant,
damit ich einfach noch drauf zeichnen kann und meine
Zeichnung dann auch gut sehe.
Also könnt ihr jetzt in dem Bedienfeld
Eigenschaften die Deckkraft etwas heruntersetzen.
Falls ihr das Bedienfeld Eigenschaften nicht sehen sollt,
vielleicht erinnert ihr euch,
in dem Menü Fenster könnt ihr es dann aktivieren.
So, jetzt setzt die Deckkraft etwas herunter,
natürlich auch nur so sehr,
dass ihr diese Schablone dann auch noch seht.
So und wenn das passt, könnt ihr jetzt diese zweite Ebene,
diese Schablone auch wieder sperren.
Geht also wieder neben dem Auge auf das Kästchen,
klickt drauf und es erscheint wieder ein Schloss.
Die Ebene ist gesperrt,
die Schablone kann sich also nicht mehr bewegen,
sie ist jetzt fest und ich muss keine Angst haben,
dass sie irgendwie transformiert oder verkleinert oder
vergrößert wird.
Jetzt geht ihr wieder auf das Pluszeichen und legt euch eure
dritte Ebene an.
Das ist jetzt die Ebene auf die wir die technische Zeichnung
legen werden.
Auch diese Ebene benenne ich um und nenne sie Zeichnung.
Die Formatierung noch einmal zusammengefasst.
Ein Rechteck zeichnest du mit dem Rechteckwerkzeug und wenn
du gleichzeitig die Shift-Taste drückst, daraus ein Quadrat.
Für gerade Linien nimmst du am besten das Linienwerkzeug und
mit der Shift-Taste kannst du diese Linie dann gerade oder
in einem bestimmten Winkel 90 oder 180 Grad
zeichnen.
Und für Texte gibt es noch das Textwerkzeug.